My kids have never eaten a store bought Pop Tart before,
and that's because they're loaded with food dyes like Red 40,
Yellow 6 and Blue Wine,
high fructose corn syrup,
soybean oil, and enriched flour.
While they don't even taste great,
they are you. And I do feel like my kids should know what a Pop Tart is.
I got to work immediately that afternoon.
I have eincorn sourdough discard piling up in the fridge,
so I decided to make these with discard
along with freshly milled whole grain eincorn flour.
Eincorn is the most nutritious wheat
because it's the oldest variety
and hasn't gone through hybridization like modern wheat.
And freshly melt has so many nutrients and vitamins.
For those with gluten intolerances,
ironcorn is a really great option.
I'm using my tree ripened peaches from last summer for the jelly
filling, sweetened lightly with low glycemic coconut sugar.
Assembling these Pop Tarts was easy
and I used a little water on my finger to act as a glue
for the bottom and top layers.
Those baked.
I made a simple glaze with powdered maple sugar and rock cream.
I tried to make the glaze red with dehydrated strawberries,
but it didn't work.
These were so much better than the version in cellophane wrappers.
My kids really liked them
and I froze them in smaller pieces for school lunch boxes.